um if you were to sort of step back as a
as a geneticist biological designer or
maybe a computer scientist computer
engineer trying to build
a
human 2.0 or maybe a robot how would you
improve
the penis and the vagina
well the penis for starters i mean let's
also discuss the testicles you know
they're very important too i mean okay
so they're yes right so they're fragile
and they're important and yet they're
hanging off the body in danger basically
so um does that make sense
you know they begin in the womb they
begin inside the abdomen and they slowly
descend and and sometimes before birth
sometimes in the first year of life
sometimes never they pop out of the body
and end up hanging in the scrotum
there's a reason because the chemical
reactions that create sperm
function best at a few degrees cooler
than body temperature and so that's why
you might notice in the warm weather
they might hang further down and in the
cold weather they scrunch themselves up
to get closer to the body to maintain
that ideal temperature a few degrees
cooler
so it's hard you know if you could
create a sperm production mechanism that
did not rely on that lower temperature
that would be great keep them inside the
body protected like the ovaries are
oh then you wouldn't rely on the lower
temperature i thought you meant
create some kind of weird internal
cooling mechanism no well
now i guess that would be one solution
but just maybe a different type of
chemical reaction or you know would not
be reliant on the lower temperature
let's say
you know it would be great to design the
spermatogenesis or sperm production
process that would function best at body
temperature and then we can keep those
delicate organs inside the body and not
have them hanging out in danger
or maybe the argument for this design is
uh
maybe
it's nice to put them in danger so you
uh are constantly concerned about it
could be maybe that's beneficial for
male psychology i'm not really sure
there's a psychological element here
about the evolution that could be so
that's testicles uh
penis
um a better way to do it you know i i
mean it's pretty good as it is you know
it kind of when it's time for it to work
it it grows and stiffens and when it's
time for it not to work it
it kind of shrinks and yeah hangs out
um saw this on a seinfeld episode so i
know how it works
shrinkage yeah that was a good one but
you know that's that's also a bit unique
i suppose that uh you know the way it's
it has this erectile tissue actually
they're similar
in the mouth of certain baleen whales
there's a certain
similar kind of erectile tissue that
helps
cool cool them off
because they have so much blubber
and creates so much heat and moving
around and feeding that they have
actually a similar similar to the penis
organ in their mouth that helps cool
their bodies because it's a big problem
they have to store all that blubber for
fuel but it makes them too hot so as a
compensation they have this kind of
erectile organ in their mouth okay
uh what about vagina you know the fact
that
miscarriages sometimes happen because of
sexually transmitted diseases because of
trauma you know it would be great if the
uterus where the growing fetus is is
sort of even more protected from those
things
um
you know i guess that's it's a side
effect of the fact that uh people still
have sex when they're pregnant are still
you know exposed to injury if there's a
way to make it uh more protected perhaps
uh that would be even better i did see
an article recently about the artificial
wombs which are
rapidly becoming a reality and in in
animal studies they're able to prolong
the gestation of a fetus by a month in
an artificial womb
can you explain the artificial aspect of
the artificial womb sure it's um
i believe it it acts almost like a a
heart lung bypass machine so when
someone's getting like bypass surgery
their heart is stopped literally they
throw ice in the chest and they um
give a potassium infusion through the
blood which stops the heart
um but the blood is run through a
machine
that uh basically does what the work of
the heart and lungs together gets oxygen
into the blood and then pushes it in
back into the body so it's i believe
it's a sort of similar mechanism to keep
blood and nutrition flowing to this
fetus
um and so it's just not inside the body
of a parent it's in some kind of other
device but i think that science is going
to rapidly improve
one benefit is you know babies are born
premature and while you know neonatology
is able to continuously kind of lower
the age of viability through better
technology and understanding how
what you can medicines and other things
you can do to premature babies when
they're born you know ideally if let's
say premature labor begins you can't
stop it
that baby's coming out one way or the
other if you could just then stick it
into an artificial womb where it can
continue its development
that would save a whole host of problems
often those babies born very early
suffer from
damage to various organs including the
brain you know for the rest of their
life so that could be a very important
technology so some aspects of the human
body
we can develop technologies that
outsource them sort of uh
offload some of the stress
and the workload from the human body to
do it elsewhere like dialysis does that
for kidneys you know people can live
decades without kidneys as long as they
get
dialysis which does the work for them
not every organ can do that for instance
the liver there's no dialysis version
for the liver like if your liver fails
you need a liver transplant and that's
the only thing that's gonna do it for
you
so that's the world's first artificial
womb
for humans and we're looking at a
picture
of what looks like gigantic balloons
matrix here we come this is very matrixy
how are they floating
what are we even looking at
there's giants
red spheres this really looks like the
matrix
um i wonder where it's from so there
seems to be a paper on this too
uh i don't know too much about it but i
did see that there it's advancing very
rapidly
the world's first artificial wound for
humans scientists in the netherlands say
they're within 10 years of developing an
artificial womb that could save the
lives of premature babies premature
birth before 37 weeks is globally the
biggest cause of death among newborns
but the development also raises ethical
questions about the future of baby
making
and so on and so forth wow
we're going to be facing a lot of
ethical questions
as we start to
mess
with human biology
in in an effort to help
human biology we might start to mess
with it
you